hi my name is leslie jones and i could
give a [ __ ] if i was conan's friend
like a flying [ __ ]
like two shits and a dog son
okay
finally
finally finally first time someone has
spoken the truth
finally someone has
thrown off
all pretense and said exactly
how they felt like what exactly yes yeah
exactly you've given voice to all of us
yeah yeah i mean you just
i don't know why people won't say it to
your face
i'm not afraid of you you know what you
know the thing is after this they will
after this everybody giving them that no
matter who i talk to and even you know
like anybody politicians are gonna be
like i don't give a flying [ __ ]
please mrs obama
no why would i [ __ ] care
please nobel prize winner
malala yeah exactly please malala
[Laughter]
who would [ __ ] give a flying dog [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] yeah
how are you you look amazing thank you i
try
[Music]
i think a lot of working out
you know a lot of fat a lot of you know
washing my face brushing my teeth type
thing
well so great to have you here thank you
you're absolutely hilarious uh it's
wonderful to have you here and i know
you have your own podcast now coming out
soon right yes it's called the [ __ ]
okay
we're not gonna have that kind of
language here oh wait we already have
yes
and it's gonna be a lot of bleeping
going on
the [ __ ] that's the name of the
podcast yes tell us what that's all
about the idea of this project it's
really uh
it's everybody's always wanting to talk
to me or hear my opinion about something
or hear me just conversate about or want
to know what i think about things and
uh at one point i was going to maybe
take over for ellen and i it's just not
a good idea just not a good idea to put
me in the middle of the afternoon
[Laughter]
and i'm not always they call in the army
you know what i'm saying like they call
it national honestly national guard like
straight guns to the head and i was just
like it's too restrictive too you know i
can't you can't do [ __ ] and you know
that so i was like i want to be
somewhere where i can say exactly what i
want to say how i want to say it and not
give a [ __ ] and there was like podcasts
yeah so me and my friend lenny we always
have the greatest conversations and
we're just
everybody that see us talked to there
was like this has got to be on something
so we decided to do it you're so great
at i've i've told you this before
i have friends of mine who
uh rave all the time about your
commentary that you do whether it's at
the olympics or whether you're watching
you know the 2020 election is happening
right someone's giving an interview and
you're there
uh
sort of riffing off of what's happening
and it can be so
funny and so so raw but also really
funny yeah but i'm just saying what
everybody's thinking yeah i think i'm
just brave enough to say
what everyone is already actively
thinking right and and i think i say it
in a way to where i try to what i try to
do is i try not to be offensive but try
to be honest and the way to not be
offensive is to be honest yeah so you
know when they were doing all the
newscasts and doing the pandemic i was
like i don't think these people realize
what they room looked like
like i know this is seriousness but i
cannot take this [ __ ] serious
when she got a picture of a dog [ __ ]
a frog
[Laughter]
like there was people in straight
torture chambers and having zooms like
what and [ __ ] going on hey [ __ ] this is
the secret room in your house
i don't think this is supposed to be
behind you
oh
what the [ __ ]
you know what's great was you're
absolutely right when the pandemic first
hit and everybody jumped on zoom nobody
cleaned up their background now what
happened i want to say four or five
months into the pandemic suddenly
everybody had the same books they had
never read never behind them a picture
of a dog that wasn't theirs flowers or
ugly ass blinds people decided to go
ahead and let people know what they're
like yeah you know like this this one
[ __ ] had a it was a whole mystery
staircase and [ __ ] [ __ ] where are you
are you in a dungeon [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] do you need help i mean i
mean some of them is like
and some of them would just not give no
effort to be in front of a white wall
and it's like [ __ ] are you hostage
do we need to send somebody in to get
you
jesus one girl was in the in the break
room i was like listen god damn it get
your [ __ ] together get a [ __ ] office
after i talked about her they got her in
office
cause i was like she's not supposed to
be in front of the nest cafe
talking about what the [ __ ] trump is
this is not i can't
george clooney to walk in this
[ __ ]